we were talking yesterday like around 4
30 4 45 eastern time and i said i feel
like i feel like kyrie is jealous
of lebron
i feel like there's some jealousy there
and then i see a story posted around 7
45 8 p.m where lebron miraculously is
talking about jealousy and the reason it
works with anthony davis
is they're not jealous of one another
now listen here we have the sound listen
to what lebron says about anthony davis
we're not jealous of each other
i think that's the
the best thing
in professional sports you have
guys that
join forces
two
you know call them alpha males that's
what they call them
two guys that's been dominated in a
specific sport on their own respective
teams
and they get together and they talk
about okay how dominant they can be and
they talk about this is gonna be this
and that
um
i believe jealousy creeps in a lot
and uh
that is the absolute
contrary of what we are
we know who we are
we know what we're about
and we want the best
seriously every single day both on and
off the floor for one another
we're just not
we're not jealous of one another and i
think that
you'll align that with respect
i don't think
i think the sky is the limit
oh let's jealous
lebron james leaves cleveland the
community is devastated not just a
franchise the community is devastated
how could he do it they hated him he
goes to miami they go to the nba finals
the cavaliers go to the lottery how they
get the number one pick in the draft who
they draft
kyrie irving
first pick in the drive kyrie irving and
they struggle a while with kyrie as
their leader and just
when they think they're about to turn
some things around they get the number
one pick again
kyrie signs a new contract with
cleveland
he's going to be the guy what happens
lebron comes back the savior comes back
and when you play with lebron
if you're anthony davis you're okay with
it
you're okay with the the narrative that
this is lebron's team this is lebron's
championship he makes everybody better
he's one of the greatest players of all
time
you have to get used to if you're okay
with that
yeah that's good
if you're not okay with that you say
wait a minute we win the championship
i don't get credit for it we struggle
he doesn't always get the blame for it
it's my his teammates didn't do enough
we win in game seven against the 73-9
golden state warriors
lebron
brings a championship to cleveland who
hit the shot in game seven it was me it
was me
why don't i get my love i want to get
out of here and the truth is that david
griffin has said this when they won the
championship right after winning the
championship he has to be traded
and they didn't trade him then and then
the next year he has to be traded to
trading him to boston hey here's a
little jealousy a little resentment
there
and i think that's what the problem is
those are two i think i think i i think
there's a distinction between those two
terms
you do i think there's a distinction
between between jealousy and resentment
yeah i do okay oh yeah i know jealousy i
think it's probably both yeah
i think it's the more the latter if
anything um
okay let's go chronological i'll address
i'll address kyrie and cleveland first
and i want to ask you about what lebron
said yesterday so let's go chronological
um
[Music]
i'm not certain that kyrie
if i could play armchair psychologist
i'm not so certain that kyrie was as
much jealous of lebron as in he wanted
what lebron had
uh as he
has an inflated opinion
i think there's a difference i think if
kyrie if kyrie thinks he's that guy
but he couldn't be that guy alongside
lebron or couldn't be recognized as that
guy alongside lebron he wanted to be he
wanted his own team he wanted to he
wanted to be the face of a franchise not
that he didn't want lebron or he wanted
what lebron had see it's almost like
there can only be one it's like no there
could be more than one but just not here
this town and this team ain't big enough
for the two of us that's not a jealousy
thing that's more of like hey i want
mine
you know like i want to be the leader
i'm ready to
evolve and grow and be the face of a
franchise or so i think but that can
never happen so long as i'm subjected to
being in lebron's shadow i'm not sure
that that's exactly jealousy as much as
it is an inflated opinion of his own
abilities to carry a franchise
you know
because he can't right he can't be
lebron he can't have what lebron is he
can't be a son of akron he can't be six
eight and 260. like i think kyrie
thinks he's as good as anybody and
therefore doesn't want to take a back
seat to lebron so it's more of a i think
he might have been competitive
with lebron but i don't know if he was
jealous as in i want what he has and i'm
gonna figure out a way to undermine him
to take it i don't know is that well you
can't understand there's a slight
difference yeah i got you all right i
got it you can't undermine them but you
know it it is beyond basketball because
you heard what he said you know the art
it's about the love and the art so i
think he sees himself as
as more than a basketball player and
it's funny when he talks about
entertainment
do you have a move doesn't he didn't he
have a movie out
yeah
uncle drew i told you i told you he was
all yeah like i mean there's nobody's
brand before he got hurt the unicorn of
boston you know disaster
nobody's brand was was was hotter than
kyrie irving's i mean he had the second
act as the second best-selling shoe of
any player after lebron got that great
commercial got that great commercial
with quest love killing it on the drums
and then kyrie dribbling
i mean you know he's
he's got a lot of things going for him
but lebron has more
sure brown has more so yeah he's got it
he's got a you know great shoe deal
lebron has a better one he's got a movie
lebron has other ones
lebron has uh he's he's a media mogul
he's got a lot happening he's got a
school
lebron is
that person who is beyond who is not
just the basketball player and here's
another story out just the other day uh
we should have talked about it yesterday
but didn't get to it but just how the
volunteers
with lebron and voting as we deal with
voter suppression a very real thing it
is 2020 uh not 1962 but there there is
it's a real story about voter
suppression
in the united states and lebron is a
part of that too
well it's so fair
maybe not that but but kyrie's got his
own voice and and and the movement for
not like that i like lebron
but let me but let me i know we up
against the break and we got company on
the other side of it so give me a second
great um you know break i want to go i
want to go back to something you said
we're in the living room you got you
take a break in your living room it's a
break
i was talking to courtney i wasn't
really talking to you and not even
audience so you know what i was doing um
what i was saying was um
oh you said lebron miraculously brought
up the idea of jealousy and i felt like
there was some sarcasm there as in do
you think
and maybe i'm reading too much into what
you just said but do you do you think it
was yeah you even told lebron's
intentional comments you think he was
responding to kyrie in a yes no
no yes okay why why would you why would
lebron be thinking about kyrie irving if
he's not if he's not responding to kyrie
because he was asked are you aware of
kyrie's comments about kyrie's comments
about hey the this is the first time in
my career
i can
i can go to somebody who's not the best
option like i am he said i'm aware and
then he left it there
so he's aware of the comments but even
if he's not talking about kyrie
okay he's not about somebody he said i
think jealousy creeps in what's he is it
just just a random comment or is that i
think i think it might be i think what i
think both okay i think it's both i
think he is recognizing through
experience his own experience with kyrie
who
so i would say the in terms of star
power correct me from wrong
um shaq who was obviously old
uh and knew that it wasn't that that
wasn't his team
d wade who the big moment in the miami
the heatless run was d wade saying hey
it's yours this is your turn we got to
follow you so that was one experience
the juxtaposition of that seems to have
been kyrie irving and having to compete
for
you know uh the crown in cleveland so to
speak or do you think kyrie was jealous
of him so now you got anthony davis so
not not to mention he's a very astute uh
student
of history uh and also an observer of
the nba and sports across the board and
and honestly
just if i could kind of go back to and
i'm not going to give another sermon
right now
but i just want to go back to like
almost like yesterday when i was
inspired by him talking about his
experience against the mavericks in 2011
what that's done for him that that spoke
to me what he said yesterday spoke to me
yeah because it's it's it's it's real
leadership
and it's a and people forget that the
the key word and teamwork is work
you know like we all have egos to some
extent but you gotta work
to to suppress that ego and push it
aside for the greater good and the thing
that i enjoy and i'll say it right here
right now the thing i enjoy about this
partnership and some of the other
partnerships i've had in my life is i
try to surround myself hell even the you
know dwayne i'm co-founding a company
with right now
uh inflection point entertainment yeah
it's i i like having partners who and
i've had partners and i feel the same
way who i am is invested in them and as
i'm as interested in their success
more so
in some cases but definitely as much as
i am my own
you know uh and and vice versa you know
i think too often just in our business
tv people like just oh you know he's a
star he's a star let's go ahead and put
him on tv they'll be great and it goes
up in flames
you know because a lot of times they're
competing with each other you and i are
not competing for air time you know you
said this at the very beginning of our
negotiation going to pull a curtain all
the way back you said this at the bottom
they were being abandoned with nbc no
curtin like there was no competition
for you when it came to me and my
contract negotiations or anything like
that
and so i i hope people listen to that
and and understand that lebron was
literally giving a leadership lesson
you know because for anthony davis yeah
obviously they go way back in knowing
each other for a long time but for
anthony davis
he's like you know somebody he's helped
raise and obviously anthony davis is
uh you know who's kind of been at
lebron's hip if you will with
uninterrupted and just they are they
they have a relationship that goes
beyond just when he came to the lakers
they known to see when his basketball
camp but lebron at this point in his
career even though he still considers
himself the mvp because we know he's
upset because you know only got 16 first
place votes he's also perhaps the most
unselfish
you know we compare him with jordan a
lot
i mean
it might be there's a lot of russell
there too there's a lot of russell there
too when it comes to like winning
he's almost robotic he's almost
unselfish to a fault earlier in his
career he's probably the most unselfish
megastar supernova that we've ever seen
in terms of he wants whether it's on or
off the court he wants to see his
friends flourish as much if not more
than he does that went longer than i
wanted i apologize i had to get that off
my chest
you